[Musique]
Salut. Aujourd'hui, j'ai fait péter la veste.
Je vous explique pourquoi
tout à l'heure.
Récemment, je me suis aperçu
que je n'avais pas fait de True Story
depuis le 2 décembre de l'année dernière
sur cette chaîne.
C'est beaucoup trop long !
Donc, aujourd'hui, je me suis dit
que j'allais vous expliquer
comment j'ai fait pour
avoir un job
dont je ne voulais pas
et dont je n'avais clairement
pas le profil au départ
générique.
[Musique du générique]
Alors oui, j'ai mis une petite veste
puisque ce soir, je suis
en première partie de
Pierre Croce.
Et oui ma petite dame,
quand je suis sur scène
je fais un effort
quand même...
En parlant de scène,
si vous voulez me voir en spectacle
il ne reste plus que
6 villes !
Rouen, Nice, Champery,
c'est en Suisse,
Conflans Ste Honorine
et Moret sur Loing, c'est près de Paris
Et Nantes, où je jouerai
pour la dernière,
si vous êtes dans ce secteur là :
venez, ça va être la grosse teuf !
Je vous le dit parce qu'après
on ne me verra plus sur scène
avant un moment...
L'anecdote que je vais vous raconter
elle remonte à 2006.
Il y a 11ans...
Ce n'est pas gentil de me faire
prendre conscience, comme ça,
à quel point je veillis...
Déjà, je sais que mes poils blancs
me le rappellent...
A cette époque là, je m'étais pris
la tête avec une pote
qui cherchait du travail,
et j'estimais qu'elle ne prenait pas
la bonne méthodologie pour en avoir.
Elle était prête à faire n'importe
quel travail en attendant pour en avoir,
et pour la motiver,
je lui ai proposé qu'on passe
un entretien d'embauche
pour une société qui est
à La Rochelle
et qui est, vous savez, dans tout
ce qui est téléphonie en fait.
Que ce soit pour vendre des trucs,
genre des assurances
des choses comme ça...
Ou, aussi, pour faire du S.A.V.
Je crois qu'à l'époque ils faisaient
le S.A.V. de Neuf.
Oui, Neuf.
Vous ne connaissez peut-être
plus le Neuf,
mais... avant, il y avait
le Neuf...
Ce qui est très gênant parce que
je suis phobique, un peu, de ce chiffre.
Donc, on s'inscrit l'un et l'autre
pour faire chacun le cursus
ça la motive que je le fasse
en même temps qu'elle,
et puis il y a un côté,
un petit peu, challenge.
Mais moi, je fais vraiment ça
pour la motiver !
Je ne cherche pas de travail
à cette époque.
Et, de toute manière, je me dis
que je n'ai pas du tout les références
et les diplômes qu'ils demandent
pour le poste.
Donc j'y vais les mains
dans les poches.
Mais le problème
c'est que pour moi, la vie
c'est un jeu.
Et dès qu'il y a un challenge,
j'ai envie de jouer
et de gagner.
Un peu comme un puzzle
qu'il faudrait résoudre.
Et ça se passait en 2 étapes.
La 1ère étape, on était un groupe de 15 ou 20,
je ne me souviens  plus exactement;
autour d'une grande table,
et on débattait, au départ,
autour d'un thème
et puis, après, il y avait
une espèce de jeu de rôle.
Les règles étaient les suivantes :
Je devais, en fait, être comme
un vendeur par téléphone,
avec, comme objectif,
de vendre !
...quelque chose de précis.
Et le recruteur se mettait
dans le rôle du client.
Celui euh...
ben vous savez, celui qu'on fait chier,
en fait, au téléphone
qui n'a rien demandé
qui a donné son n° de fixe,
un jour, dans un magasin
qu'on a revendu à une société.
Bon.  Ben lui incarnait
cette personne là.
Et le thème c'est que je dois vendre
des bûches de bois compressé.
Donc, des petites bûches
qu'on met dans la cheminée.
Mais ce que je ne savais pas
c'est que le recruteur
avant d'être recruteur,
c'est un vendeur.
Et pour lui, il est au top du top
dans sa tête.
Et là, il va se mettre à jouer
le client chiant, potentiellement, avec moi.
Sachant que moi, j'étais en train de vendre
quelque chose que je ne maîtrisais pas
et que je ne connaissais pas.
Je n'avais aucune info
sur le produit.
Donc, c'était un gros Battle.
A chaque fois qu'il me donnait
un contre-argument
comme quoi il n'était pas intéressé,
je trouvais un meilleur contre-argument
à son contre-argument,
mais en utilisant, toujours,
une logique implacable.
Et je sens que ça l'agace.
Je vois que ça l'agace que,
devant les 15 à 20 personnes présentes,
je sois capable de le mettre
un petit peu à mal, en fait.
Et, pris d'énervement,
je le voyais rougir, aves les narines
qui commençaient à se dilater,
donc on était pas loin de la colère
quand même...
"Mais de toute manière ça ne m'intéresse pas,
je n'ai pas de cheminée !!! "
Et je me suis dis : "Toi mon gars,
tu me tends une perche magnifique."
Alors j'ai changé mon fusil d'épaule
et là je lui ai dit :
"Ah, vous n'avez pas de cheminée ?!"
"Écoutez, Monsieur, je tiens à vous adresser
les excuses de la part de notre société,
quelqu'un, en amont, a mal fait les fiches
et nous n'étions pas censés vous appeler,
puisque vous n'avez pas
ce besoin potentiel.
Donc, encore une fois,
excusez moi de vous avoir dérangé,
et nous allons supprimer
votre numéro des listes."
Si le mec n'a pas de cheminée,
on n'était pas censé l'appeler
et l'avoir dans un fichier client.
Bref...
Ça l'a agacé.
Mais l'observateur,
donc il y avait un recruteur
et un observateur,
je pense que ça lui a plu
puisque je suis passé en dernière étape.
Et la dernière étape, c'était un recrutement
en individuel dans un bureau
donc on faisait tous la queue,
en fait, on attendait.
Ceux qui avaient été "sélectionnés",
un petit peu...
Et on avait 5 à 10 min. d'entretien,
après, dans le bureau.
Donc j'étais assis dans une espèce
de salle d'attente avec d'autres personnes,
et comme je m'ennuyais un peu
j'ai pris la brochure de la société.
La brochure, elle faisait,
de mémoire...
entre 50 et 70 pages.
Bon, je sais, c'est large,
mais je ne me souviens plus exactement.
Ce dont je me souviens, par contre,
c'est que je me suis amusé
à apprendre
chaque page.
Alors, non pas par coeur et en entier,
mais d'apprendre le thème principal
de chaque phrase,
le simages clefs,
les valeurs clefs qui étaient
mises en avant...
J'ai utilisé, tout bêtement,
une table de rappel pour ça
comme j'ai déjà pu vous l'expliquer
sur la playliste mémoire.
J'ai été reçu en entretien,
qui était une sorte de discussion,
et je ponctuais toutes mes réponses
de :
"De toute manière, comme vous l'expliquez
dans la page 23,
il faut d'abord améliorer
la relation clientèle..."
Et ça a été ça durant 5 à  10 min.
Ce qui est hyper-bluffant
pour la personne en face,
parce qu'elle a l'impression que
tu connais tout, ligne par ligne,
alors que ce n'était pas vrai.
Mais c'était déjà pas mal d'avoir retenu
tous les thèmes généraux de chaque page.
Et j'essayais, justement,
de les replacer.
Et la finalité de tout ça
c'est qu'on m'a rappelé
pour m'offrir le job
que j'ai refusé ! Parce que, vraiment,
je ne voulais pas faire ce travail là,
je ne voulais pas aller faire ça
chez eux,
en plus, je n'avais pas besoin de travail
et je n'étais pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce système de fonctionnement.
Par contre, ce qui est chouette,
c'est que ma pote a eu le taffe,
ce qui lui a permis d'avoir du travail
durant un certain temps,
ce n'est pas vraiment ce qu'elle voulait faire,
mais en attendant de trouver mieux,
c'était très bien.
Alors, pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça ?
Ben déjà parce que vous m'aviez demandé
une nouvelle True Story.
Et les Stories, c'est le seul truc où
on se met des défis de likes.
Et ça fait un petit moment que
celle du 2 décembre
a passé largement le quota
qu'on s'était donné.
Pour les stories, je mets un défi
de likes hyper-haut,
c'est volontaire. Ce n'est pas forcément
du like pour du like...
C'est aussi pour qu'il n'y en ait
pas trop fréquemment sur la chaîne.
Il n'y en a eu que 4 l'année dernière
sur 366 vidéos.
Donc là, le prochain quota, il sera à...
disons euh...
1O% des abonnés.
On va dire 40.000 !
A 40.000 je referai une story.
Donc ce sera peut-être
dans très longtemps.
Alors, j'ai aussi choisi cette anecdote
parce que je la trouve marrante.
Si vous voulez, je n'avais pas vraiment
les compétences pour avoir ce taffe là.
Mais en utilisant 2 techniques
de mentalisme, en fait,
une sur l'argumentation rationnelle
et une sur la table de rappel,
qui sont des choses très simples
que je vous ai expliquées sur la chaîne,
et ben,
juste avec ces 2 choses là,
on peut essayer de choper un job.
Et ça répond aussi, un peu,
à la question :
"Ça sert à quoi le mentalisme
dans le quotidien ? "
Ben voilà.
Ça peut servir à ça.
N'oubliez pas, et je vais le dire
très très vite,
les dernières villes :
Rouen, Nice, Champery, Conflans Ste Honorine,
Moret sur Loing et Nantes !
Pour les dernières dates
du spectalce !
Liens, dans la description !
Le livre qui sort le 18 mai : lien dans
la description pour le pré-commander.
Et je suis dans une de ces phases de
reconnaissance où j'avais envie de vous dire :
Merci d'être là !
Les 464750 !
Merci !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner.
Un petit pouce en l'air.
A très bientôt.
Ciao !!!
[Musique du générique de fin]